on
mais là messieurs bonsoir aldo moro et
vivent la plupart des italiens qui
viennent ici se recueillir ou déposer
une gerbe sur les qte endroit où il a
été enlevé il ya plus de cinq semaines
la plupart des italiens en sont donc
personne est persuadé depuis hier soir
ce journal il n'est pas de zéro a publié
en édition en pleine page un portrait
d'un aldo moro presque souriant et tout
le monde est persuadé chez les
enquêteurs que la photo est trop
authentique que le communiqué des
brigades rouges également
alors donc aldo moro serait divan mais
peut-être n'est-ce qu'un nouveau sursis
qui expirait en même temps que le délai
qui sépare des brigades rouges pour un
éventuel échange
demain 15 heures et tout cela justifie
que nous consacrions d'ici là la
première partie de ce journal et puis
demain l'édition de la mi journée samedi
et demi à essayer de comprendre le drame
italien
qu'est ce qui arrive à ce peuple qui à
bien des égards nous est si proche et je
dirais même essayer de le comprendre
avec sympathie car rien n'est plus faux
que les schémas préfabriqués quand on
parle de l'itouch qu'est ce que cette
décomposition de l'état cette dilution
des responsabilités que sont ces
brigades rouges qui depuis 6 ans vont
régner impunément ici la terreur
songez plutôt que leurs effectifs ne
dépassent pas le millier de militants et
qu'il a suffi pour eux d'une dizaine
d'enlèvements de personnalité d'une
vingtaine de victimes par attentats dont
10 policiers six minutes à l'extrême
droite prend magistrats et un
journaliste pour que tout d'un coup
l'italie ait peur et pour qu'elle soit
comme on dit déstabilisés alors tout
cela nous allons essayer de le
comprendre
et d'abord comment travaille la police
tout pourrait laisser penser ici en
italie que ce sont les brigades rouges
qui ont le jeu bien en main la péripétie
des recherches du lac de la duchesse
démontre que même au delà du raisonnable
les autorités sont prêtes à suivre
n'importe quelle piste quel que soit le
lieu où l'heure cela peut paraître pour
certains un aveu d'impuissance pourtant
la police ne néglige aucune piste aussi
incroyable soit elle mais parallèlement
le travail de fourmi continue il faut
trouver l'éguille dans la meule de foin
et pour cela on ne lésine pas le
matériel de communication le plus
sophistiqué a été mis en place
en quelques secondes une voiture de
patrouille peut recevoir un message
écrit ou la photo de suspects recherchés
sans avoir à repasser par le quartier
général pour remonter la filière des
brigades rouges ont d ici en italie que
la police devra avoir de la chance on
fait sans doute allusion à la fuite
d'eau qui a permis de découvrir
l'appartement arsenal de la viagra dolly
il faudra aussi de la méthode la chance
viendra c'est possible de l'accumulation
d'informations par laquelle arrivera
peut-être la solution il faut faire vite
si l'on veut éviter que la sphère moreau
ne soit suivie d'une autre tout aussi
délicate les brigades rouges n'ont pas
caché leurs intentions
il convient de cas c'est l'engrenage
sous peine de mort au pluriel dans le
bâtiment de la quest ou rhin le quartier
général de la police dont la salle
opérationnelle ressemble à une clinique
les policiers informaticiens qui
travaillent 24 heures sur 24
reçoivent et transmettre un
rassemblement les informations ils
peuvent à tout moment être questionné à
distance
on sait que le moindre détail placé dans
un contexte particulier peut prendre une
importance considérable
il ne faut que quelques secondes pour
connaître le passé d'un suspect nous
avons fait l'essai avec renato curcio le
cerveau des brigades rouges
il suffit de taper le nom de l'intéressé
et attendre
renato curcio est né le 23 9 41
association de malfaiteurs le 25 5 72
même date troublent l'ordre public
association de malfaiteurs le 22 11 72
hold up
le 18 5 75 séquestration de personnes le
12 de 74 et trouvés porteurs d'armes 25
5 72
même chose le 22 11 72 c'est un homme
dangereux s'est signalé le 21/06 74
troublent l'ordre public le 24 5 75
son surnom est erronée
dans cette phase de l'enquète la parole
est maintenant aux savants qui étudie
les documents et la machine à écrire
découverte viagra dolly mais ce qui
semble très important c'est la
découverte des explosifs et des armes
ouais
les experts ont sept jours devant eux
pour apporter leur conclusion c'est la
première fois depuis le début de
l'affairé aldo moro que les policiers
détiennent
autant de pièces à convictions et ses
pièces à conviction ce sont
essentiellement des âmes et on sait
parfaitement ici dans les locaux de la
police
chez les experts que ces armes parlent
on peut déterminer la provenance on sait
parfaitement qui l ont été vendues ou
même si elles ont été volées
après les expériences nous en serons
certainement beaucoup plus sur les
agissements et les ramifications des
brigades rouges
on a souvent parlé de collusion entre
les brigades rouges et la bande à baader
on a laissé entendre qu'il existait
peut-être une international terrorist
les armes saisies apporteront sans doute
des indications intéressantes à ce sujet
ce qui explique le secret absolu
ordonnée par le juge d'instruction
les laboratoires sont gardés secrets
ainsi que le nom des experts
on sait déjà que certaines balles
calibre 9 mm proviennent de la même
série que celles qui ont tué les gardes
du corps d'aldo moro ce renseignement
est le premier d'une liste qui pourra
bien être longue
voilà j'ai tout juste eu le temps de
remonter dans les studios de la rai et
je pense que vous l'avez perçu au
travers de ce reportage de philippe
gassot la police italienne commence à
être contesté ici on dit qu'il n'ya pas
beaucoup de coordination entre les
différents services services secrets
policiers carabiniers puis l'armée parme
équipe la première fois participe au
maintien de l'ordre c'est assez dire que
l'italie a déclaré la guerre aux
terroristes alors voilà le point de l
enquête à 20h de l'ultimatum fixé par
les terroristes alors rires maintenant
victor vraiment les implications
politiques oui ou non le pouvoir va-t-il
céder au chantage
alors évidemment tout le monde attend
une prise de position officielle de la
démocratie chrétienne mais voyez vous je
ne pense pas que la démocratie
chrétienne va à dire oui ou non à une
négociation avec les terroristes
il y à différents risques ça aussi la
démocratie chrétienne dit non aux
théories ça risque de braquer les
brigades rouges et ça qu'on promet
d'autant la vie d'aldo moro
mais si d'un autre côté la démocratie
chrétienne accepte de négocier
il va y avoir évidemment des remous dans
l'opinion publique parce que d'après un
sondage que j'ai sous les yeux
76 7 % des italiens sont tout à fait
contraire à toute forme de négociation
avec les brigades rouges
harry communiste maintenant les caennais
sont très fermes est une addition de
négocier ils sont beaucoup plus faire
parce que ce n'est pas leur président
qui se trouve entre les mains des
terroristes position très ferme
effectivement mais il ya aussi une autre
donnée c'est que tout ne dépend pas de
la démocratie chrétienne et rien d'autre
que le pouvoir il ya la magistrature
on peut imaginer que la cour d'assises
de turin qui est en train de juger
renato curcio et ses camarades de membre
des brigades rouges
on peut imaginer que la cour d'assises
ordonne la liberté provisoire des
terroristes mais dans ce cas là il y a
le procureur général de turin qui dit
non et qui pourvoit en cour de cassation
cela s'est d'ailleurs déjà produit dans
le cas de mario ceux ci jugent qu'ils
avaient été enlevés et là aussi le
tribunal avait ordonné la mise en
liberté provisoire des terroristes mais
la cour de cassation avait cassé
le jugement du de la cour d'assises et
il faut rappeler que c'est à turin
effectivement que sont toujours
emprisonnés les brigades rouges derrière
leur chef et notre coach ou alors qui
sont ces terroristes qui apparemment ont
trouvé en italie un bouillon de culture
dans lequel il se déplace un petit peu
comme des poissons dans l'eau et bien la
réponse nous sommes nous allés la
chercher auprès de l'un de nos confrères
italiens car vous avez qu'ici les
journaux ont des rédacteurs spécialisés
qui ne s'occupe que des brigades rouges
c'est par exemple le cas de mario cela
qui est journaliste à l'express nous
l'écoutons interrogé par philippe gas en
six mois les racines dans des réalités
sociales très précise de match vous
payez philippe les deux dans d'autres
pays par exemple en allemagne et aux
etats-unis et en italie sont
l'expression de l'exigence qui se
reproduisent continue par exemple
évidemment surtout du milieu ouvrier
on ne croyait pas il ya quelques temps
que les brigades rouges étaient dans les
usines
si on écrivait ça on se faisait dire que
ce n'était pas vrai qu'on était des
provocateurs et maintenant on a pris on
a des brigadistes et on a découvert ce
que certains individus soutenait depuis
longtemps certains observateurs et des
commentateurs politiques de gauche
qu'ils aient depuis longtemps que les
brigades rouges existe dans les usines
sont des ouvriers et qui se cache même
avec dans la poche
la tête c'est la commande il à la carte
la carte du pci et de temps en temps est
très souvent la carte des syndicats
voilà donc ce soir ce que nous pouvions
dire un moment où toute l'italie retient
son souffle
il est évident que s'il se passe quelque
chose de nouveau à tout moment nous
intervenons dans le cadre de ce journal
en direct de rome est avec vous
maintenant patrick lecocq le reste de
l'actualité en france et ailleurs dans
le monde à commencer suppose par la
ferme de ce détournement de boeing ce
nouveau détournement
oui paris parlera voyage bien surprenant
en effet pour les 97 passagers aussi les
13 membres d'équipage du boeing 707 des
lignes aériennes coréenne qui effectué
hier le trajet paris séoul via anchorage
en alaska selon moscou cet avion en
effet été interceptés hier soir par la
chasse soviétique alors qu'il violait
l'espace aérien russe il a été content
radis moscou de se poser à une
centaines à plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres de moscou un millier de km
environ de la capitale soviétique sur un
lac gelé
et là c'est là qu'on ne comprend plus
très bien ce qui s'est produit hier deux
personnes deux passagers ont en effet
été tués soit en vols soit lors de
l'atterrissage et deux autres ont été
blessés
alors on se demande s'il n'y avait pas
un pirate de l'air à bord du boeing 707
corée en tout cas selon washington
l'armée de l'air soviétique n'a pas
hésité à ouvrir le feu dans l'air contre
sebring des lignes aériennes civiles
coréenne
les vacances se terminent pour beaucoup
de vacanciers le travail va reprendre
dès lundi dans les écoles de la zone à
ces vacances qui se termine nous
permettront de faire le point dans les
prochains jours sur ce qui s'est passé
durant cette dernière quinzaine
en bretagne on saura alors si la marée
noire et la pollution ont eu des
répercussions sur le tourisme mais pour
l'instant que les bretons regarde plutôt
vers le large il se demande si les
décisions prises à londres par
l'organisation maritime internationale
vont être rapidement suivis des fêtes à
landry hier on a parlé de catastrophe et
des catastrophes causées par les
pétroliers et on a décidé que désormais
les super tanker n'aurait plus le droit
de naviguer à moins de 50 km d'ouest en
est à moins de 37 km des côtes du
cotentin
une nouvelle réglementation donc georges
leclercq un nouveau système de
circulation sur ce que l'on appelle le
rail oui exactement il ya deux zones
très dangereuses vous l'avez signalé
dans la manche pour la pour les français
c'est bien sûr large de ouessant près de
landreau s'est échouée l'amoco cadiz là
les navires naviguait à 10 km des côtes
où près et sont désormais rejetée à 50
km dans les rails du moins les
pétroliers et les autres navires
pourtant des matières potentiellement
polluantes
les déchets radioactifs ou le plomb
tetra est il donc souvenez la
catastrophe de 30 et du brésil et bien
l'autre zone c'est un peu pareil
vous avez le récif des casques et ici
l'île d'aurigny c'est une zone
potentiellement dangereuse puisque les
pétroliers qui remonte la manche sont
pleins ils viennent du golfe persique ou
d'autres régions pétrolières et vont
décharger en europe
donc là aussi on a pris une décision n'a
repoussé ce couloir à une trentaine 35
km du cap de la hague
le couloir en plus c'était largy il sera
balisé par des très grosses
oui les navires navigueront comme dans
une autoroute on appelle la manche
l'autoroute
ici ce sera vraiment vrai alors cette
décision en principe est applicable
immédiatement mais en pratique il faudra
du temps parce qu'il faut refaire les
cartes il faut instruire les équipages
et il faut aussi établir les
réglementations
l'elysée tient à ce que ça soit fait le
plus tôt possible mais ce petit d'élèves
a quand même demandé au moins six mois
alors les bretons pense que quand même
ça va les protéger puisque le fait de
repousser le rail donne plus de temps
d'intervention en cas de pépin en cada
varient comme l'amoco cadiz on a subi
merci georges conséquences aussi de
cette marée noire le conseil économique
et social a proposé que soit nommé un
monsieur catastrophe pour le conseil
économique et social ces le secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'intérieur
qui devrait occuper ce poste il pourrait
être chargée d'assurer la coordination
en matière de sécurité civile dans le
cas d'inondation de séisme d'un incendie
de naufrages ou de catastrophes en tous
genres en attendant cette éventuelle
nomination si le projet bien sûr est
retenue par le gouvernement
c'est la marine nationale qui est chargé
tout au long des côtes françaises de
faire la police ce qui n'est pas simple
il faut dire qu'en mer une fois sortis
des eaux territoriales les marins sont
libres pratiquement de faire ce qu'ils
veulent
et si sur une route nationale on peut
arrêter un automobiliste qui roulait à
peu trop vite il est presque impossible
en mer de stopper un super temps de
guerre qui a décidé de ne pas s'arrêter
elle constaté avec ce reportage de jean
louis lesaint cherbourg 8h le matin le
pacha du patrouilleur la combattante est
sur le pont
dernière vérification le navire peut
quitter arsenal
il ne rentrera au pork deux jours plus
tard la mission de la combattante
traquer les navires qui circulent en
infraction dans la zone de séparation
des eaux au large des casquets une zone
interdite de cap km sur 20 qui isole les
voies du trafic le rail descendant et le
rail montant
c'est le centre de recherches
opérationnelles du cap de la hague qui
centralise les informations données par
radio mais pour tous les responsables
qu'ils appartiennent à l'armée ou à la
marine marchande
les moyens sont encore loin d'être
suffisant pour être totalement efficace
plus la restauration ainsi que continue
sa route la différence à la zone de
séparation dont gérard natif que nulle
sur l'hymne
c'est également pour attendre de france
mais débourser s'écoute comme éteinte le
contrevenant est un cargo danois qui
s'appelle hermann j'appelle hôtels et
corps mais au mac os car delta fait
route à contre sens dans l'eure et loir
pour prévenir le drame de l'amoco cadiz
évidemment d'une part la couverture
hazard doit être terminé et l'autre par
la présence de remorqueurs aux points
sensibles de notre littoral remorqueur
qui pourrait être de la marine nationale
ou affrété par la marine nationale par
exemple
finalement c'est une heure vous n'allez
pas les moyens actuellement de faire
tout ce que vous vouliez faire à bas
pour le moment les moyens on les a pas
mais il est bien clair que des plans
sont prévues telle sorte que ce soit
fait dans des délais plus que
raisonnable c'est à dire c'est à dire
que je pense que wes en civil et la
station de ouessant doit être mise en
place très rapidement on peut penser
mais tu es 6 mois 1 an ici ou gasquet
s'est réalisé et à green essais réalisés
aussi
grosse mois de la combattante je remonte
le client il me paraît à l'intérieur de
la zone de séparation pouvez vous me
confirmer par les ai reçus je vais
l'identifier tennis tennis de six
banques ont battu 12 notes comme plein
trafic se positionne rousseau va de ses
soins fourchette la combattante
how do you read 20 bâtiments de guerre
français la combattante pour contacter
le vent me recevait vous parlez bon
alors mauvaise volonté est patente
par notre présence devant un effet
dissuasif nous relevons les
contraventions au trafic est dense et de
contraventions sont relevés en banlieue
avec et transmis aux autorités
concernées mais finalement ça sert à
quoi
alors ça sert à faire rentrer dans les
moeurs des commandants de bateau qui
passe par ici l'habitude d'emprunter les
règles de circulation maritime quand été
édictée par la france et par la grande
bretagne l'année dernière qui sont
devenu impératif blindés dernière et qui
assurera aux pratiques maritimes une
meilleure sécurité
est-ce que ça a vraiment un effet à
l'heure actuelle cela ça un effet
donc il est encore difficile de mesurer
l'importance mais qui à la longue ce
sera certainement un procès verbal pour
chaque infraction se soldera par un
rapport envoyé aux autorités du pays
concerné il arrive que des sanctions
soient prises
mais lorsque le navire bat pavillon de
complaisance force est de constater que
c'est rarement le cas les compagnies
préfèrent encore la ligne droite pour
aller d'un corps à un autre au risque de
provoquer une collision
et puis la mentalité des marins n'a pas
encore suffisamment évolué en fonction
du trafic
ils refusent souvent en eaux
internationales l'autorité d'autrui ils
sont toujours maître à bord après dieu
bien entendu placé du débat au sein du
parti communiste français après les
élections monsieur guy hermier députés
communistes des bouches du rhône évoque
ce matin dans l'humanité le formidable
tapage fait autour du débat qui se
déroule dans les rangs du parti
communiste français pour monsieur guy
hermier il s'agit toujours pour la
droite d'affaiblir le pc afin de créer
les conditions d'un éventuel recours au
parti socialiste des socialistes ils
sont d'ailleurs appelés à réfléchir sans
entrave par le rédacteur en chef de la
revue du ps faire patrick viveret estime
qu'au moment où les militants du parti
communiste commencent à organiser un
vaste débat sur les causes de l'échec
on comprendrait difficilement que le
parti socialiste évacue ou bac
cette discussion lundi le comité
interministériel d'aménagement des
structures industrielles va ouvrir le
dossier
boussac aujourd'hui à l'assemblée le
ministre de l'industrie monsieur giraud
qui répondait à une question du député
des vosges monsieur seguin a rappelé les
efforts importants consentis par l'état
en faveur du groupe textile qui est
actuellement près menacé pour monsieur
giraud le gouvernement a pour
préoccupation fondamentale de sauver un
outil industriel valable mais non de
sauver l industrie particulière ou bien
telle structure juridique dans la sphère
boussac
on approche donc maintenant du
dénouement mais le rétablissement de la
situation ne sera pas facile
cheval appartenant à marcel boussac
journal appartenant à marcel boussac
maison de couture appartenant à marcel
boussac marcel boussac 80 ans était la
plus grande fortune privée de france
lempire du coton aujourd'hui tout se
défait il y à la concurrence étrangère
le vieillissement du matériel une
gestion à l'ancienne qui n'a pas su
s'adapter aux lois nouvelles du marché
résultat des pertes et un endettement
qui se creusent et les usines qui
tombent une par une
en dix ans les cotonnière du nord les
usines de normandie la moitié des
établissements des vosges
l' empire du coton est devenue une peau
de chagrin
pourtant les tentatives de redressement
ont été nombreuses le vieux marcel
boussac a fini par laisser les rênes à
son neveu jean claude qui continue à
négocier d'acrobat x échéances avec les
banques et avec l'état depuis peu il est
assisté d'un expert en restructurations
l'ancien pdg de manufrance jacques petit
côté emploi les fermetures les pré
retraites et les licenciements ont
réduit le personnel à 11500 salariés
dont 6000 dans les vosges qui attendent
sans illusion nous avons nos sources de
renseignement et nous sommes sûrs
maintenant qu'il y a eu un plan qui a
été élaborée avant le avant les
élections législatives
et ce plan prévoit il était suspendu
bien sûr à à cause des élections
législatives mais ce plan prévoit
justement 2500 suppressions d'emplois
dans l'ensemble du groupe boussac est
surtout ici dans la région dans le
secteur des vosges ici en dehors de
boussac les possibilités d'emploi sont
dérisoires
la restructuration va tomber sur un
personnel et des syndicats qui sont le
dos au mur ce sera dur pour toulouse
pendant ce temps là près de paris les
pur-sang de marcel boussac ignore que
les 85 hectares de leur domaine sont
hypothéqués jusqu'au dernier mais ce ne
sont que des chevaux le premier ministre
monsieur raymond barre a poursuivi
aujourd'hui ses entretiens avec les
syndicats il a reçu ce matin une
délégation de la cftc
puis cet après midi une délégation de la
fin la fédération de l'éducation
nationale
ce matin donc monsieur jean-bernard le
secrétaire général de la cftc a insisté
sur la nécessité d'éviter que la
restructuration des entreprises ne se
traduise justement par des licenciements
anarchique et il s'est montré exigeant
sur les conditions permettant de
relancer la politique contractuelle
qu'en ce qui concerne la politique
contractuelle qui est un autre point de
l'entretien en ce qui nous concerne nous
n'avons pas affaire de reconversion sur
ce terrain depuis les élections nous
restons farouchement partisans de cette
politique contractuelle
nous avons eu un débat assez serré avec
le premier ministre pour lui dire qu en
ce qui nous concerne nous ne pouvions
pas avoir simplement des salaires
évoluant comme les prix mais qu'il
fallait lier l'évolution du pouvoir
d'achat à l'expansion et aux résultats
des entreprises
à 16 heures monsieur andré henry
secrétaire général la fen soumettait au
premier ministre cinq dossiers traitant
des conditions de travail de salaire
dans la fonction publique
mais c'est surtout de la formation des
jeunes dont on a parlé nous sommes
assurés que une discussion va
s'instaurer sur le problème de
l'insertion sociale et professionnelle
des jeunes
d'abord pour la suite du pacte de
l'emploi de manière à améliorer ce qui
peut l'être car tout est loin d'être
parfait dans ce domaine et qu'une
négociation aura lieu également sur les
problèmes de la formation initiale avec
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
cette fois l'engagement est pris pour
voir comment le service public peut
mieux répondre aux besoins de la nation
et en même temps aux aspirations de la
jeunesse
le président du gabon monsieur omar
bongo était l'hôte à déjeuner ce midi de
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing à
l'elysée le président bongo peu après ce
déjeuner a reçu le ministre tchadien des
affaires étrangères qui est actuellement
en visite dans notre
le tchad est en effet revenue à la une
des préoccupations des autorités
françaises la situation au tchad s'est
sérieusement aggravé depuis quelques
semaines à l'elysée on a démenti hier
l'envoi de renforts français verne
djamena mais d'ores et déjà plus de 500
soldats français se trouvent sur place
pour instruire l'armée de shania depuis
12 ans dans les oasis et les déserts du
nord du tchad des rebelles 5000 hommes
environ mène une lutte armée contre le
gouvernement central au début de cette
année les combats ont repris les
rebelles du frolinat armé par la libye
ont occupé la préfecture de faya largeau
capturant ou tuant près de la moitié de
l'infanterie tchadienne dans l'armée
comprend onze mille hommes le 27 mars un
accord de cessez le feu est signé à
benghazi entre les deux camps mais il
n'est pas respecté
dimanche dernier le frolinat poursuit
son offensive et attaquent la garnison
de salal deux instructeurs français sont
tués
la france qui était intervenu
directement dans le conflit jusqu'en
1971 à retirer toutes ses troupes du
tchad après la crise provoquée par la
ferc l'austr en octobre 1975 le dernier
contingent français qui te djamena de
nouveaux accords des accords de
coopération sont signés en 1976 il
prévoit une aide importante en matériel
militaire et la présence au tchad
d'instructeurs ou d'assistants
militaires français qui sous l'uniforme
tchadien n'ont en principe pas le droit
de participer aux opérations de guerre
ou de maintien de l'ordre
il y aurait actuellement sur place 5 à 6
ans assistant militaires français à la
demande du gouvernement tchadien
il semble que des légionnaires aurait
également été envoyés au tchad
information non confirmée à paris où
l'on espère encore comme à djamena la
reprise des négociations
enfin le dollar a continué de monter sur
les places étrangères alors que l'or lui
a reculé aujourd'hui raisons de cette
hausse de la monnaie américaine
la décision prise par le gouvernement de
monsieur jimmy carter de vendre une
partie des réserves d'or américaines
quant au franc français il a amélioré sa
position aujourd'hui face aux devises
fortes c'est à dire face aux marques et
au franc suisse
rapidement avant de retrouver patrick
poivre d'arvor à rome les autres
informations de cette journée monsieur
helmut schmidt le chancelier fédéral
ouest allemand recevra jeudi prochain le
prix de la fondation louise weiss ce
prix lui sera remis dans la grande salle
du palais de l'europe à strasbourg
mais monsieur schmitt se préoccupe aussi
de sport on avait parlé il ya quelques
jours d'une éventuelle intervention du
chancelier ouest allemand pour que
kaiser franz franz beckenbauer face à
nouveau partie de l'équipe nationale de
football ouest allemande une information
qui a toutefois été démentie aujourd'hui
si monsieur schmitt a beaucoup de
pouvoir en allemagne
il n'a pas celui encore de choisir les
joueurs du onze national il laisse ce
soin à un autre hellmuth helmut schön le
sélectionneur 12,3 en france en football
toujours nous connaissons maintenant le
tirage au sort des demi finales de la
coupe de france sochaux affrontera nancy
et nice rencontrera monaco match aller
le 5 mai match retour quatre jours plus
tard le 9 mai à cannes pas de tirage au
sort mais un vote du jury qui ont fixé
le palmarès au prochain festival et on
connaît d'ores et déjà les titres des
films présentés par la france il y aura
deux courts métrages maladie de paul
vecchiali et la traversée de
l'atlantique à la rame de jean françois
laguionie et puis il y aura de longs
métrages
le dernier film de claude chabrol
violette nozière et enfin le molière
d'ariane mnouchkine à films coproduits
d'ailleurs par antenne 2 et nous avions
pu suivre il ya quelques mois quelques
unes des scènes de tournage de ce
molière
300 figurants 500 masques 800 costumes
un budget d'un milliard et demi de
centimes
la cartoucherie de vincennes transformer
en annexe d'hollywood
un film qui durera quatre heures animé
par une équipe qui fonctionne en partie
en coopérative ouvrière
c'est vraiment une étrange super
traduction les principaux acteurs du
film tous membres du théâtre du soleil
touche le même salaire participe à
l'intendance règle les mouvements de
foule
d'où cette atmosphère bon enfant au
désordre apparent en fait parfaitement
contrôlée espérons qu'ils auront aussi à
se partager la palme d'or du festival de
cannes
la météo pour demain après une matinée
fraîche et localement brumeuse dans le
centre et le sud ouest le temps sera
bien ensoleillé
il aura toutefois encore des nuages sur
les vosges le jura et les alpes
quelques orages en corse et sur
l'extrême sud est et peut être aussi
quelques petites pluies fines après des
côtes bretonnes
les températures seront à la hausse
voilà donc pour cette actualité tels que
nous pouvions l'avoir ce soir à paris
patrick poivre d'arvor à rome je suppose
qu'il n'y a rien de neuf dans la sphère
aldo moro et bien neuf en effet patrick
lecocq sinon bien sûr j'aurais
interrompu votre journal les sept
journalistes qui m'accompagne ici michel
halal victor vraiment philippe gassot
philippe rochot bernard cuisse sauget
françois renaud patrick voix sont tous
sur les lieux du suspense près les
téléscripteurs ou prennent nos confrères
italiens de la rai mais rien ne filtre
pour l'instant il va donc falloir
attendre une nouvelle nuit de suspense
pour savoir quel sera le résultat de
l'ultimatum le dernier ultimatum lancé
par les brigades rouges qui je vous le
rappelle expire demain donc demain
samedi à 15 heures alors à tout moment
évidemment nous pouvons réintervenir
soit dans votre dernier journal donc à
22h50 soit surtout à 12h30 demain dans
le cadre de notre émission samedi et
demi puisque elle sera consacrée
uniquement au drame italien et sera
faite aussi en direct de rome comme ce
soir avec temps vraiment je recevrai un
représentant de la démocratie chrétienne
un représentant du parti communiste du
parti radical
un sociologue un metteur en scène de
cinéma qui tous à l'aide de documents
qui seront tournées par nos équipes
essaieront nous faire comprendre
un peu mieux ce drame italien ce drame
que vivent nos amis de l'autre côté des
alpes
voilà je pense que maintenant je peux
vous dire à tous une très bonne soirée
si possible l écoute d'antenne 2 à
demain donc
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir que
s'est il donc passé hier soir dans
l'espace aérien soviétique alors qu'il
est et devant le peu d'informations
fournies par moscou en continue de
s'interroger sur les raisons qui ont
amené l'avion de ligne réguliers paris
séoul via anchorage en alaska à se poser
sur un lac gelé à l'intérieur de l'union
soviétique
ce que l'on sait ce soir c'est que deux
passagers de l'appareil ont été tuées et
13 autres blessées
le boeing 707 des lignes aériennes
coréenne transportait au total 97
passagers et 13 membres d'équipage
ce que l'on sait aussi c'est que le
pilote n'a pas posé volontairement son
appareil il y a été obligé par des
chasseurs à réaction soviétique
chasseurs qui aurait même ouvert le feu
alors que l'appareil civile survolait la
région de mourmansk
selon les informations fournies aux
états unis par l'union soviétique
l'avion avait demandé à atterrir en urss
après avoir pénétré dans l'espace aérien
russe mais selon moscou son approche
aurais tu un caractère agressif et en
conséquence les l'aviation soviétique
aurait tiré et l'atterrissage ne se
serait pas déroulé dans des conditions
normales
la compagnie aérienne coréenne conteste
ce soir les déclarations soviétique pour
elle il n'est pas pensable que
l'appareil est que l'équipage se soit
trompé aussi grossièrement alors que le
vol s'était déroulé parfaitement
jusqu'en norvège
on en saura probablement plus lorsque
les passagers sont à leur tour en
occident cinq français étaient à bord de
cet avion corps et la tante continue en
italie ce matin la famille de monsieur
aldo moro a lancé un appel pressant la
démocratie chrétienne et au gouvernement
italien pour que soit sauvé la vie du
président du principal parti politique
italien la tente se poursuit l'ultimatum
fixé par les brigades rouges pour ouvrir
des négociations devant aboutir à la
libération de terroristes emprisonnés à
turin expire demain en début d'après
midi
les démocrates chrétiens ne pourront
rien faire depuis un mois les autorités
italiennes réaffirme jour après jour
leur volonté de ne pas traiter avec les
ravisseurs de monsieur aldo moro alors
un peu partout on envisage des solutions
c'est ainsi que le président du conseil
de sécurité des nations unies monsieur
andré jung a convoqué aujourd'hui les
membres de ce conseil pour des
consultations sur un sujet humanitaire
le conseil de sécurité pourrait lancer
un appel unanime et de portée mondiale
en faveur de la libération
de monsieur aldo moro le premier
ministre monsieur raymond barre a
poursuivi aujourd'hui ses consultations
avec les principaux dirigeants syndicaux
français ce matin monsieur raymond barre
a reçu le secrétaire général de la cftc
on a parlé restructurations
industrielles évolution des salaires est
aussi politique contractuelle et puis
cet après midi le premier ministre a
reçu durant une heure et demie les
dirigeants de la fédération de
l'éducation nationale
c'est avec 5 dossiers sous le bras que
monsieur andré henry secrétaire général
la fédération de l'éducation nationale
abordait cet entretien avec le premier
ministre
thème de ces dossiers le problème des
maîtres auxiliaires la situation du
service social et de la santé scolaire
la formation et l'emploi des jeunes
ainsi bien sûr que les salaires dans la
fonction publique
à l'issue de cet entretien monsieur
andré henry se déclaraient
particulièrement satisfaits par le
dialogue établi et il confirme à la
prochaine ouverture des négociations
nous avons parlé des négociations
salariales dans la fonction publique
elles s'ouvriront en mai il est à peu
près sûr que une progression de pouvoir
d'achat pourra être envisagée pour les
plus basses rémunérations aucun
engagement du premier ministre a été
pris sur les autres sujets mais il nous
est apparu très sensible sur les
problèmes de la grille de la refonte de
la grille et nous avons quelques espoirs
aussi de ce côté
grande soirée sportive il y avait du
football ce soir mais aussi de la boxe
et du basket la boxe était à toulon le
championnat de france des poids welters
louis acariès le tenant du titre mettait
son titre en jeu justement quand à la
rue locaux nous attendons le résultat de
ce combat de boxe nous l'auront
peut-être avant la fin de cette édition
il y avait du basket aussi avec un match
au sommet villeurbanne le mans au sommet
mais qui conteste j'ose dire pour du
beurre puisque tout est réglé en choper
la france de basket et villeurbanne l'a
emporté 96 à 84 donc devant le mans et
puis enfin thierry roland il y avait du
football oui c'était la 35e journée du
championnat de première division plus
que trois journées donc avant la fin de
ce championnat il suspense continue du
moins en tête du classement puisque les
quatre premiers monaco nantes strasbourg
et marseille ont tous les quatre gagner
en marquant pas mal de buts du reste eu
beaucoup de buts de marqués en sept
soirs et 36 pour les dix matches de
première division
je vous propose de regarder donc ces
résultats donc monaco a battu
saint-etienne à monaco par 3 buts à 1
buts de rouquette de françois et de
aunis pour monaco but du jeune rousset
pour saint-etienne victoire de nantes à
valenciennes but de paix coûts et du
jeune ailier gauche junior aniol qui
effectue ses débuts dans l'équipe de
nantes
en ce qui concerne strasbourg c'est marx
guemriche et specht qui ont marqué les
trois buts strasbourgeois et à ce qui
concerne l'olympique de marseille
boubacar a réussi trois buts et berdoll
un but voilà pour les équipes de tête en
ce qui concerne la queue du classement
on peut dire que reims a fait un pas
important vers son salut aujourd'hui
rien n'est réglé mais enfin les rémois
respire un peu mieux ce soir grâce aux
cinq buts qu'ils ont passés à trois
lances malheureusement a perdu à paris
contre le paris saint-germain
je vois mal comment lens pourrait éviter
maintenant la descente en deuxième
division qui l'aurait cru
lorsqu'en début de saison les lensois
disputé avec brio la coupe d'europe mais
c'est ainsi il y à des renversements et
des bouleversements dans une saison de
football
voyons comment les lensois ont perdu le
premier but allait revenir
grâce à une action extrêmement
tranchante du demi parisien adams qui
allait surprendre toute la défense de
lens il traversait le rideau lensois se
présentait seul devant leclerc et dans
un angle pourtant fermé et malgré le
retour de deux défenseurs marqué le
premier but à la 56e minute de la partie
d'une partie qui n'avait guère été
passionnante jusque là les lensois
allaient accuser le coup et sur ce
corner tiré par le jeune brice on aime
plaies de la tête sont à plus haut que
tout le monde ait marqué le deuxième but
à la 72e minute dès lors s'en était
presque fait des chances de lens lens
qui allait pourtant repartir avec
beaucoup de courage à l'assaut du but
défendu par bernard et obtenir à 13
minutes de la fin un but qui lui
redonnait espoir pour une petite dizaine
de minutes sur un premier tir de l'eau
clair que nous allons voir dans quelques
instants vous verrez l'ailier gauche
international didier six bien suivre le
ballon et marquait le but de lens
malheureusement un but qui sauve
l'honneur relais le tir de leclerc 6 a
suivi deux à résultat final merci
thierry toujours pas de résultat pour le
match de boxe pour le championnat de
france je vous donne donc demain midi la
météo pour demain la matinée sera
fraîche et encore localement brumeuse
mais ensuite le temps devrait être assez
bien ensoleillé il pourrait y avoir
encore des oranges en corse toutefois y
aussi dans le sud est
le printemps arrive en tout cas les
températures vont sérieusement remonter
voilà pour l'actualité de ce vendredi je
vous souhaite de très bien terminer
cette soirée en compagnie de ludmilla de
shirin à votre prochain rendez vous avec
l'information c'est samedi et demie
diffusée demain en direct de rome quant
à moi je vous retrouverai demain soir à
20 heures
bonne fin de soirée donc avec salomé